i'm going to throw this at you guys i
want to kind of kick it off by saying uh
personally
i love everything about it from a
personal perspective because
um it's it's basically giving you the
insight that you need to know to be
successful in life and with women
and most guys don't want to do the work
which is even better so that just you
know increases the odds of your success
in my view
the downside to it the stuff that i
don't like about it as a creator from
that perspective is mostly the whinging
and whining that's you know it's mostly
the complaining and and then like you
know there's just a lot of guys that are
not willing to do the work that are that
are interested in hearing about
you know the insight but they don't
actually apply it they're what i call
the red pill [ __ ] they'll just
watch one stuff after the other or they
even subscribe to the drama or
um you know you get these so-called
coaches
somebody said here on my community tab
when i asked the questions dude said how
diluted the spaces become with so-called
coaches who couldn't even change a flat
tire on their car let alone offer good
advice to young men
and he's not wrong because the barrier
to entry is pretty low all you need is a
computer and an internet connection what
about you guys what's your personal view
on your problems with the red bill
yeah there's a lot of crossover when i'm
i'm teaching people uh seminars or
privates or whatever not so much
privates because it's one on one
but with seminars you know i go through
the technique i show the details i
explain what's going on i ask everybody
if they understand what's going on
everybody shakes their head yes you know
i have their attention and then we break
and then everybody's in their small
group or with their partner
supposed to be drilling the technique
and working on the technique and
they're just shitty chatting
they're not they're not really they're
like oh yeah yeah i got it i saw what
you did and uh maybe they try it once
but then they uh they stop there they
don't they don't try to master the skill
they don't try to master the technique
which takes a lot of effort regardless
of whether or not the technique is going
to fit into your game precisely
you still need to drill the hell out of
it to make sure you understand it to
know
how it works how you can teach it to
somebody else or how to you could defend
against it because you know the moving
parts and how that stuff's going to work
and it gets frustrating because you know
like you're wasting time taking up space
i got limited numbers i can have in my
seminar
and there's other people out there who
would really like to
do these things and
i think there's a lot of crossover with
that in the red pill with guys who
consume endless content
uh watch the videos read the books but
then they never actually go out and do
anything about it um
yeah like we were talking about this
before because john did um
like your theme was it in july or was it
in august was about like inner game like
building yourself
in your game
it was one of your lowest viewed um you
know pieces it's the same thing with my
playing the win content right like i
have a playlist or a podcast that i call
playing to win it's like it gets views
and people love it but it doesn't get
nearly the same views as if you put
something out like hey you know five
things you need to understand about
women it's like okay
yeah um
well
how much time you got
uh you know there's only three of us
right now so
go man i'll put you full screen let them
have it the the thing is just that you
know
there's just a wealth of
information out there and i mean wealth
in regards to the quantity
the amount of quality
information out there is abysmal
somebody will just put in their name
you know
redpill dude 69 on twitter and he'll
just know how to like
game the twitter algorithm or game the
youtube algorithm
or uh put you know like you know for
example like no no offense to the you
know the guy whatever
like coach red pill right it's just like
some fat guy in his 40s
it's just like this guy all he does is
get on the on youtube and cry
and i'm like this is this is red pill is
your are your tears red pill i actually
like gonzalo
i i think i think i think fun i think
he's just like in i think he's just like
intellectual i just think that's what he
is i think i don't think he's like a guy
who walks the walk i think he's just
married with kids i mean he's you know
he's not playing the game right now
right but i mean so are you and you're
jacked
um well you're not married
[Music]
[Laughter]
you must be jacked to be listened to is
that what you're saying young padawai
i'm getting there no but i'm just saying
like if you're going to call yourself uh
you know something the red pill whatever
um you know you got to look the part as
well and another part is this right
there's
the bottom line it's like there's just
uh wolf 69420 exactly chad boner yeah
you know these guys they don't seem like
okay one of the guys who lives the most
red pill
like sex late in life that i know is my
buddy mac the day gamer and you probably
have not heard of him because his
youtube channel is awful and his
thumbnails are trash like he's getting
better he's doing a good job
but
the guy is out there
running through girls i'm talking like
three to four super hotties a week and
just has a steady rotation all he
focuses on is making money
lifting weights and running through
chicks his youtube presence is is pretty
much non-existent and awful because he's
out there living the life and most guys
who are living their life they're not on
the internet blogging about it they're
not writing about hey i'm like some
alpha chad like when john was fighting
george st pierre and you know
you know knocking people out in in
multiple mma organizations he wasn't
like okay guys i'm gonna go start a blog
and talk about how i'm i'm the man right
he was out there like
going to the wild sex parties and and
having like the the the you know the
millionaire events and meeting all the
celebrities and and banging all the
hotties right so
do you need to be running through a
bunch of women to be listened to because
both ryan and i are in ltrs right but
you have ran through women
you know what i mean some of these guys
never have ever right
and um
it's just it's hard to find but but but
my notch count is 1400 john
right
exactly and you live in a filthy world
country
and so
um
you know
there's just it's just the number one
problem is there's a lot of
pseudo
coaches a lot of pseudo resources out
there and we're seeing a lot of these
guys getting debunked as internet
grows destroyed right yeah they're
they're getting more and more debunked
because uh you know you leave a digital
trace everywhere you go
and uh like for example um what's that
guy like tell your tell your son this or
what was his name
yeah he got destroyed by uh tate
he got he he's talking about how he's
like champion alpha and he's the best
ever and he's like literally simping for
a cam girl over a long-term relationship
that he's having that's country to
country
so
he's writing all this stuff about being
this champion alpha and all this stuff
but he he's literally getting cocked by
uh
a a a cam [ __ ]
and so the biggest problem with the red
pill in my opinion is just
there's there's a lot it's just hard to
find credible sources and there's a lot
of try hard dudes that try to compensate
internally because they they feel like
they're not man enough they feel like
they're really not masculine enough that
they have to make a youtube channel and
they have to like make a blog presence
they have to make a twitter following
and then they think oh now that i've
cultivated this audience now that i've
cultivated this following
now i have value and my red pill views
are valid and i'm a valid as a man and
then you have like an army of idiots
following him and this bad information
is spreading everywhere ultimately like
you said it's good for guys like you and
i rich because it just thins out the
herd in regards to competition
um but it's just hard to find credible
sources out there but people seem to
conflate
high viewer count high subscribership
um high like ratios with like oh this
must have value but i mean fundamentally
that's like the
that's like opposite of what the red
pill is like if the masses are agreeing
with you you should look at yourself in
the mirror and be like okay what's wrong
um that that kind of raises a point carl
uh
i retweeted him yesterday he doesn't
come on twitter much these days but i
retweeted him yesterday he made a point
about
the sphere the sphere where the hell is
it so the one about black pill being a
lifestyle choice no no no no it was one
about like
getting the views and opinions of other
people when you should be making up your
own mind after a while um yeah oh yeah
where new guys come to the space because
they don't know any better and so yeah
they're the ones that need advice but by
the time you've established yourself you
should [ __ ] know without having to
ask the internet oh did twitter [ __ ]
remove it for crying out loud is that
what they did well here do you want to
fill time while you find it or yeah go
ahead phil so dude ryan yeah the hating
the red what is your grievance with the
red pill
i love these conversations yeah and i
don't have a good answer because like
john
absolutely right he said things there's
guys that aren't living life these
aren't doing this alphas don't run a
blog
every example though that i find of
things that matter you're going to find
another example of where it does case in
point
roycey everybody could argue roycey very
red pilled
ran through notches all that stuff he's
got the receipts to prove it wrote to
seven uh the unbearable triteness of
hating basically saying you know
people that gave me [ __ ] over the last
seven years this is the [ __ ] they gave
me and one of the examples you know
alphas don't blog they're too busy
meeting women he goes yeah because you
know we don't have [ __ ] hobbies
but john's right there's a lot of guys
who just make a random channel thinking
they can be red pill for 2069 and do
[ __ ]
alpha will flip to four yeah alpha wolf
yeah maybe you need to be jacked to be
red pill but then
they used to say that about power
lifters remember that where they always
show mark riptoe and everybody's like
yeah he's too fat to be i trust him with
my fitness advice meanwhile he's the guy
who wrote the book on strength training
anonymous guys can't be alpha but we all
know carl and he's crushing in his life
so it's like every time we come up with
like a hard and fast rule
you can always find an exception you
don't have to look hard yeah so then
it's always yeah so then what is
what does make somebody credible in the
red pill and i've realized the only
thing that i can find that doesn't come
with an exception
is guys who don't give a [ __ ] about
their audience
do you know what i mean i must be the
most good pill
yeah well no it's like i tend to agree
with that because i mean if if we cared
about like what people's opinions were
right you can do all of these response
videos which we almost never do i mean i
never do anyway or
you'd care about getting the view counts
which would mean that we would put a
dramatic you know red meat sort of
content which none of us do yeah and i'm
not saying you don't get to care you
don't have to care like obviously people
care if you're doing something nobody
wants to be a piece of [ __ ] at it yeah
to be useful from that perspective but
that validating from the audience i find
that is opposed to what most people do
that i've loved and respected and like
enjoyed over the years they're people
who are just doing their [ __ ] and
they're documenting it almost like an
autobiography
yeah that stuff i love like i'm
listening to you talk about you know uh
you had thing on beard you showed me
this one video you had on how to take
care of your beard you weren't
telling some guys what you think they
wanted to hear to be a bigger man with a
beard you're like i fixed my beard and i
do this simple thing guys try this out
you're probably gonna love it and i
think that was like
the exact perfect what i hate about the
red pill is that nobody wants to swap
notes anymore everybody just wants to
take my notes you know or take your
notes you know what i mean right and i
find that's the horrible thing and it's
just pandering
it's no different yeah don't sim for the
women simp for me yeah and don't simp
for guys either is what i've been saying
too is stop simply for channel creators
i mean you look even just as pathetic
too
you